. David, Donald Trump is increasingly talking
about.
Giving businesses immunity from Corona virus
related lawsuits.
Does this make sense or should employees always
be able to sue, sue and seek damages from
their employer?
If they were to catch Corona virus as a result
of being back at work?
Listen, this is really a complicated issue
from a practic, from a logistical sense, from
a legal sense, where you have to understand,
well, what is the current liability that employers
have?
Is catching Corona virus the same as an unsafe
warehouse where you get run over by a forklift
because the forklift didn't make the beeping
noise and have the red light that it's supposed
to have and steel toed shoes weren't requite.
Right.
These are these are very different questions
when it comes to something like Corona virus.
If you go to work and you catch Corona virus
and everybody was behaving safely and the
employer has opened in accordance with CDC
guidelines, foreign state guidelines for OK,
employees need masks and the employees had
masks, there should be X number of sanitation's.
They if all the rules are being adhered to
and people catch corona virus.
It's very difficult to say that the employer
should be liable for that, particularly when
the contagion may have happened because of
some random customer or who knows.
It's a very difficult legal question.
But should there be some blanket immunity
for employers?
Of course not.
We have an infrastructure for determining
when an employer is or is not liable for something
that happens to an employee or to a customer
on the premises.
It is very robust legislation.
It is very established.
There is no shortage of cases of all kinds
about employers who failed to protect employees
and customers or who were sued.
But it was determined they actually did take
the proper precautions.
The danger here is that for political reasons
and for the purposes of furthering what is
become a culture war overgrown virus, Donald
Trump is seeking to give blanket immunity
for anything corona virus related that happens
in their place of business when they reopen.
And what this is really about is employers
who are not following the guidelines that
Trump wants to see have immunity so that they
will just open up even when it is not yet
safe to do so on the basis of the guidelines
that have been put in place.
This is about Trump wanting to give a carte
blanche sort of situation to employers that
want to reopen.
And even though the state says you need masks,
they don't want their employees to wear masks
and in some cases may even tell their employees
no masks whatsoever.
So for me, the last thing we need is any blanket
immunity for employers.
But I am sensitive to the reality that your
employer can be doing the right thing and
you might get coronavirus versus your employer
might not be doing the right thing.
Those are the situations that need to be adjudicated.
Listen, here's the reality.
If you're an essential worker at a grocery
store and you continue working.
We know that the longer you are in places
where the virus is circulating, your odds
of contracting it go way, way up.
Spending 15 minutes with a mask on at Trader
Joe's.
Even if there are people in there with the
virus is not hugely likely to end up with
you getting the virus, spending eight hours
a day, five or six days a week there, even
with a mask dramatically, still sees an increase
in the chance that you get it.
Does that mean the employer is acting inappropriately
and should be sued?
No, not necessarily.
What I do think is that essential workers
should be compensated additionally for the
fact that they are essential and are often
some of the least well-paid people.
That's a battle I'll have all day long.
But if employers really are being safe, we
have a system that would adjudicate that and
would say this lawsuit has no merit.
The employer did the right thing.
Everybody did the right thing.
We have a contagious situation.
If grocery stores should have been closed,
that's a bigger governmental call that should
have been made.
But we don't need any special dispensation,
as the case may be, from Donald Trump or the
federal government to shield a Priore employers,
because employers may take advantage of that
and some will take advantage of it to have
deliberately unsafe conditions that they believe
are better for them in the short and maybe
medium term.
You could say, listen, over the long term,
if all your employees get sick and a bunch
of them die, it's bad for PR.
You're not going to have employees.
OK, there are lots of industries that have
such turnover as it is that they regularly
have a stable of applicants and they can bring
people in.
Quickly and trained them relatively quickly
for relatively unskilled labor.
Many businesses would not really be concerned
about that.
So no blanket immunity.
We have a system that can determine, is this
a valid claim or is this what we would call
a frivolous claim?
They don't need any special bailout.
It's part of the culture war.
It's part of this haphazard desire to open
the economy fully, immediately, regardless
of what the repercussions are.
In my experience, any blanket immunities for
corporations from future lawsuits are bad
news.
I am open to the idea that sometimes they
are OK.
I looked today for examples.
Couldn't find any.
If you have an example.
Absolutely.
Let me know.
We have a great bonus show for you today.
I hope you will be there.
Get a membership at join Pacman dot com to
get instant access.
And remember, you can sign up for free for
the daily audio podcast of the show.
A lot of people don't know.
There's a daily hour long podcast.
It's on iTunes.
It's on Stitcher.
You can find the feed link on our website.
It's available.
Make sure you're signed up for that.
Pat's got the bonus show today.
I'll be back on Monday.
The David Pakman Show David Pakman dot com.